à renforcer les sanctions contre la
russie elle est totale les présents la
république a été très clair hier sur le
fait qu'il pouvait y avoir dans ces
sanctions le secteur énergétique ou
death in menace l'europe de représailles
alors que l'union européenne prépare un
nouveau train de sanctions contre la
russie le président russe veut
surveiller je cite les livraisons
alimentaires vers les pays hostiles au
kremlin vous devez exclure la russie
oui c'était l'agresseur est la source de
cette guerre vous venez de me dire que
poutine est un criminel de guerre sans
doute pas du moins de la ja crimes de
guerre et la responsabilité de poutine
et de l'armée russe mala évidente donc
de fait votre raisonnement est juste
quand donc maiden avez raison de parler
de coeur et de boucher elle ne doit pas
pouvoir bloquer les décisions concernant
sa propre guerre
sinon il faut dissoudre votre assemblée
on doit pouvoir faire mieux que parler
le président américain joe biden réclame
un procès pour crimes de guerre contre
vladimir poutine ce type est brutal et
ce qui se passe à abuja et scandaleux
tout le monde la ville si vous regardez
les cadavres qui n'existait pas avant
que les troupes russes n'arrive des
fraudes à la jeune troupe soit
ne parte pardon avant qu'elle ne parte
et soudain ils apparaissent certains
montrant des signes de vie on ne peut
échapper à la conclusion que c'est une
mise en scène la création la cour pénale
internationale est une initiative de
clinton après la yougoslavie et que
c'est le congrès américain qui a refusé
de valider bon donc quand on danse des
accusations pourraient faire passer
quelqu'un devant une cour pénale
internationale et que on y adhère pas
soi même c'est déjà quelque chose de
piquant
renforcement du déploiement russe
le sud de l'ukraine pour essayer de
l'ensemble du drum bass et crée un pont
terrestre à la dcc clooney en termes de
massacre et en termes de guerre illégale
évidemment dans l'ordre de priorité dans
l'antichambre la cour pénale
internationale devrait y avoir les les
blés bush père et fils
il devrait y avoir certains de soldats
moi ce que j'ai appris récemment que
trouver le plus extraordinaire c'est un
massacre qui a été fait par cette
société privée qui s'appelle blackwater
en irak qui est l'équivalent d'un wagner
ses volets qui a tué je crois quatre
personnes en violant la fille et les
quatre types qui ont été condamnés par
la justice américaine ont été amnistiés
par trump regard des positions qu'il
avait prises avec marine le pen pendant
des années d'être votre tante a raison
cette soumission à leur fille comment
vous exprimiez un regret est là avec
vous disiez on s'est trompé et voire
même que vous vous tézier parce qu une
forme d'indécence après un monsieur les
encenser poutine pendant des années il
faut être prudent se souvient de
timisoara se souvient de la guerre en
irak il ya eu beaucoup de manipulations
comme ça d'image je dis ça veut pas dire
que c'est le cas je dis simplement il
faut être prudent il faut attendre une
enquête voilà internationale pour parler
des ukrainiens que vous adulez mais
depuis 2014 il ya une guerre civile en
ukraine dans l'est 14 mille morts sous
les bombardements du gouvernement
ukrainien dans le donbass ça ça vous
intéresse pas parce que ce sont des
morts qui ne rentrent pas dans votre
narrative c'est aussi le résultat de la
pression qui a été exercée par l'otan
sur sur l'ukraine donc pour moi ce ne
sont pas eux ne sont pas la solution et
d'ailleurs on voit bien qu'ils n'en
n'ont pas pour que cessent ces atrocités
et pour contrainte vladimir poutine a
retiré ses chats d'ukraine il faut
l'embargo expulsé quelques diplomates
russes
sérieusement c'est de la blague enfin
ces rampes en fer d'ambassadeur de
russie en france quelques mois où je
suis depuis le début
comment dire prudent sur ces sanctions
parce que je sais que je ne veux pas
c'est que ça se retourne contre les
français et c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer après les pizzas but tony 7
autour du chocolat ferrero rappel des
tonnes de produits kinder produit en
belgique pour cause non pas de
colibacilles cette fois ci mais de
salmonelle josé badia
moi j'étais une merde
et puis soudain
ça parle